if someone did that to me I think I
would send them a bomb but I don't think
that's fair right a bomb a homemade bomb
that is a felony okay I wouldn't do that
then yeah what if someone sent you uh
WNBA season pass oh then I'm [__]
[Music]
definitely did you guys hear about how
Petty eBay executives are no way that
means you already love this yeah yeah I
like this so um Executives of eBay sent
live
spiders what and
cockroaches to um a couple after they
produced a newsletter that the eBay
employees disliked uh and now the couple
has sued eBay and one in court because
of emotional psychological and physical
Terror that was incited by them what do
they do like send a bunch of spiders in
a package so eBay's former senior
director of Safety and Security targeted
the couple for producing e e-commerce
bites a newsletter that the company's
Executives weren't happy with it
basically um pissed them off and
so eBay decided to deploy acts of
intimidation oh wait wait wait hold on
yeah yeah so this couple that works for
eBay no no no they they have a
newsletter about oh just e-commerce it's
kind of like restaurant magazine or
whatever so just a random newsletter but
they're probably talking on eay yeah
yeah talking whatever you know which is
is there any examples of Contex as like
what type of they wrote so it it says
that they it doesn't talk about that cuz
this is mostly about how the couple sued
in one oh the acts of intimidation
included sending live insects oh my a
fetal pig and a funeral wreath to their
home in massachus what's a funeral
wreath a wreath that goes on a coffin or
something yeah that oh
they have like the the easel for
whatever reason oh yeah the one that's
like this and Dead face in the middle
their pictures that's almost like a
violent threat yeah dude oh yeah
especially coming from like a giant
[__] company too bugs though dude
hear me eBay executives are [__]
Petty dude that's cuz it's like they're
getting a bad review on eBay oh yeah
right and they worked hard on their
store the little eBay
store they're just a mom and pop yeah
you're you're telling me you're fighting
for your life reached out to me before
you left the
rating eBay does suck though eBay sucks
they could have been Amazon but up watch
what you say Ryan oh yeah I'm going to
get I'm going to get some bugs in the
mail no no no not just that not just
that so the eBay Executives also
installed a GPS tracking device on the
couple's car dude they really did all
this [__] that's gangster and they
created posts on um the website
Craigslist inviting sexual encounters at
their home oh that's a good one really
classic it's a classic see every time
Steve reads something that they did he
just Smiles a little bigger dude I'm
also like licking my lips a little B
yeah yeah dude he's team e that's
[__] hilarious and it sounds like
Ryan did all these that one's underrated
as hell like that will ruin your phone
Ryan's definitely done them all before
it ruins your number non-stop horny yeah
non-stop horny all
hours keep calling don't stop calling
yeah yeah yeah they go straight to your
front door HMU all C just show
are you sure you're not they're like
sorry no this is not the
place I was so horny too you said be
naked at a Ral upon a rival with whipped
cream in one hand yeah dude these These
are Executives I want to know what this
newsletter said about eBay I know right
and how many times have they used these
tactics to intimidate people uh that's a
great question these are veteran moves I
think yeah yeah this doesn't seem like
this is like you've been getting away
with it for a while like escalation yeah
that's going to be a class action
lawsuit all these cases come forward but
what's funny is like they're tping a
house basically at that you know it's
like what what if you did this to the
wrong person I know man so uh yeah so
these guys got sued for uh $3 million
and and they're they have to pay oh I
hope they Su them personally not the
company what's that did they sue the
company they usually do right I think so
yeah but I feel like it should come out
of the pockets and they should face
Criminal charges because that's all
right Joe come on man criminal charges
what's going on it's just a little prank
man you're I thought you're man of the
people's on dude it's funny man come on
we had a big old laugh couple bugs
couple insects I'm a big uh Underdog and
you can keep the GPS I think that the
GPS part's the crazy part because that
shows how well they had physical access
to their belongings that's kind of like
so did they have like a eBay like let's
say shoe seller go and do the Dirty Work
he came up and [__] did the the thing
like how many people did they have under
their P well they were probably like
this person's actually ordered from eBay
before we have their address they
couldn't they couldn't get the shoe
seller because it turned out he was a
Chinese guy not in
America what do you mean you live in
Connecticut you don't live in
Connecticut which is why eBay sucks it
does man it does so the all the
employees in question were fired by eBay
after the incident one of the guys was
um he was the manager of Safety and
Security senior dor yeah he was keeping
eBay safe and secure I can see like this
dude he should get a raise he took his
job serious dang man I I didn't know
eBay was hurting that bad are they
hurting that bad I think they're
struggling I'm so curious how they found
out who the per the people was cuz like
I'd be like where the [__] is this
coming from and like I know it's eBay
but who in the how they built such a
good case that's true it's a really good
point cuz you wouldn't believe if your
wife was complaining to you like eBay's
doing this I know eBay's coming for me
man what are you talking about I know
eBay is doing this it's [__] big eBay
unless unless internally eBay just chose
Fall Guys yeah oh could be dang yeah we
don't know but um apparently the the
couple who was writing the newsletter
right um said or uh no the the guy who
got fired right the the head of Safety
and Security he said he faced pressure
from former eBay CEO to re in the
Steiners over their coverage of the
company that's what he's saying about so
he's like I was just pulling the [__]
jobs for this big guy I was the trigger
man so it was the CEO's idea he that's
what he's saying from it's coming from
the top I believe when people say [__]
like that because if you work corporate
you're probably not lifting a finger
unless somebody's paying you to do it
yeah nobody wants to do [__] no one's
extracurricularly [__] with anybody
incorporate it's it's a game of like I
want to give you my job so I don't have
to do my job yeah but I also Imagine
like top head big dog CEO not [__]
giving the details like send them
spiders you know what I mean he's
probably he's probably like take care of
it take care of I don't want to know
right and then this guy's like I'm going
to send him
spiders and's like what the [__] were
you thinking that's not what I meant
take care of I me spiders I meant talk
to him [__] he that's really funny if
that's what happened that is funny you
said them creepy crawlies he's like I
got a guy I got a guy he's a little
weird but he'll get the job done go get
the message hey don't worry boss I'll
take care of it all right let Leslie do
his thing Leslie a man named Leslie you
don't want to mess with him you don't
want to mess with him I got a spider guy
and he's also a caterpillar
guy his side hustle funeral
REITs that's yeah that's a crazy one bro
he manages a mega mall it's a big jump
to funeral it's not even on game so
funny the boss just wanted him to remedy
the [__] tension like offer him a
discount or something why the [__] did
you say s them bugs sent them Anthrax
instead a Craigslist
account that's crazy dude the the array
of things they did or or it's got to be
like one of those it's like a room like
this where they're like you know closed
doors talking [__] on the situation yeah
we should just send them bugs and the
guy just [__] takes everything
serious The Writer's room of pranks yeah
oh okay cool yes in a porno Craig Craig
sex house yeah the Craigslist one by
itself should have been enough that's
terrible know
you get the lowest of the low coming to
your door that's really really rough so
the acting um Massachusetts us attorney
general Josh Levy told the AP News eBay
engaged in absolutely horrific criminal
content oh
[__] dude horrific that's so funny wow
it's like the garage sale
Mafia at least it puts eBay back in the
news and you think the the CEO of offer
up is As hardcore as the eBay guys or
what no all that dude does is show you
ads that don't have a close button just
leave oh yeah I'm always s of like where
is it where where I know it's here
somewhere oh I got to wait 15 minutes
for it to show up the ad free always
trying to sell me ebikes and [__] stop
they know you though dude they're
selling me kids ebikes they know you I
think it's called the guardian
or hats are working that sounds like a
sex toy dude now everyone watching it's
going to get that
ad dude petty man so petty these are
your people Del
abely which one's your favorite one out
of all the whole three I think the the I
think anybody opening like spiders is
like very
confusing cuz it doesn't S it doesn't
deliver a message it's just like oh
somebody accidentally sent me spiders
like it doesn't like accidentally yeah
cuz it doesn't mean like oh this is a
threat to me spiders inside of a
container what if they just all crawl
over the place that's different if you
release spiders that's different that's
not what it is they didn't open it oh
it's it's in a cage oh it was it in like
a paper and then cuz that's you're like
oh that's going the trash live insects
on the label it's like if someone did
that to me I think I would send them a
bomb but I don't think that's fair right
a bum a homemade bum that is a felony
okay I wouldn't do that then yeah what
if someone sent you uh WNBA season pass
oh then I'm [__]
definitely I'm chopping off one of their
[__] friends heads and then sending
that back to
them they're going to get a [__] head
of their friend the star SE passes are
the aces the aces season passes no yeah
why could I got spiders foundy the first
degree I'm just going to bend over and
take that
huh season passes we're not available
for purchase season passes are like
[__] $25 can you get season passes
I'm sure oh comes with parking and
that's why people get them you probably
buy once they park your car and they
drive it all the way up to you too comes
with parking they actually pick you up
from your house and they take you to the
stadium and they drive you
home and you going to sit in a suite
yeah dude they got a chef next to you
making you [__] whatever you
want and people still don't making the
table siiz
[Music]
sushi